Is it bad to pause the rife or if I can't finish a ball one night?
Oh, so if you're saying, you know, the night program is nine hours long
and you've got had to get up in seven and a half hours, should you pause it?
No, don't pause it. Just let it run out or just turn it off and start the next night
with the next program. No, don't worry about that.
Not everybody gets all their night timed out every night. You just don't.
So that's why every night is a little bit different.
You know, there's a lot of the same frequencies at each night.
I flip flop them so that I realize you're getting up to one of the bathroom at different times.
You, you know, you get interrupted. You have to wake up early. So that's why I do that.
So that you're not missing out any frequencies. Don't pause it.
Just let it time out or turn it off and start the next night, the next day.